nächste Rednerin Alice Weidel aus der
AFD sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte her Bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren die beiden Vorredner
haben eindrucksvoll gezeigt dass es
ihnen an Ernsthaftigkeit für die wahren
Belange und Probleme der Bürger in
diesem Lande
fehlt es
brennt es brennt in Deutschland und
diese Regierung aus überforderten
Fehlbesetzung und starsinnigen Ideologen
ist der Brandstifter die geschundenen
Leistungsträger dieses Landes gehen auf
die
Straße Bauern Handwerker Mittelständler
Gastwirte Händler
Transportunternehmer sie protestieren
weiter weil sie nicht mehr
können verschwiegen von den
Medien dreivierel der deutschen stehen
hinter den
mittelstandsprotesten
dreiviertel wünschen sich ein Ende
dieser
Regierung sie ziehen eine Schneise der
Verwüstung durch dieses
Land aber statt zu korrigieren setzen
Sie sich an die Spitze einer
beispiellosen der Kinderbuchautor sitzt
da Frau
esken setzen Sie sich an die Spitze
einer beispiellosen Verleumdungskampagne
wie gerade hier eindrucksvoll
geschildert gegen die
mittelstandsproteste und gegen die
Oppositionskraft auf die immer mehr
Bürger ihre Hoffnung setzen frei nach
dem Motto wird der Bürger unangenehm
bezeichne ihn als
rechtsextrem ihre
hilfsstas
Korrektiv vielen
Nichtregierungsorganisation die von
ihrer Regierung mit reichlich Steuergeld
versorgt wird hat ihn dafür die Vorlage
geliefert mit unglaublichen Lügen
Verleumdung und übelster
Nachrede und die Chefin von
Korrektiv lügt jetzt ein vor sich hin
sie hätte das Wort Deputation nie
benutzt soweit ist es schon gekommen
steuerfinanzierte denonzination gegen
eine
konkurrenzpartei sie schämen sich nicht
einmal sie schämen sich nicht einmal das
Demonstrationsrecht zu pervertieren ein
Freiheitsrecht der Bürger gegenüber dem
Staat und nicht umgekehrt statt den
Menschen zuzuhören die ihren not in die
Öffentlichkeit tragen demonstrieren sie
selbst gegen die Opposition und sie
finden auch nichts dabei wenn auf
solchen Demos ganz offen
Mordaufrufe gegen oppositionspol zurell
wer
AFD töten steht dort und sie klatschen
Beifall der
Bundespräsident bezeichnet AFD Wähler
als Ratten und die FDP Spitzenkandidatin
AFD Wähler als Schmeißfliegen schämen
sie sich schämen sie sich in Grund
[Applaus]
und umdungs und rufmordkampagnen Spalten
Sie dieses Land und nur um sich an ihre
eigene Macht zu
klammern die Reparatur der
Reparatur eines missglückten und
aufgeblähten Haushaltsentwurfs ist ein
Dokument ihrer Arroganz und ihres
Unvermögens sie reden vom Sparen aber
sie bürden die Lasten allein den Bürgern
auf die Stimmung Unternehmen ist am
Boden die Ampel ist das größte
standortrisiko für
Deutschland mittelständische Unternehmen
werfen reinenweise das Handtuch und
ergreifen die Flucht die Liste der
Firmen die ztaus Stellen streichen oder
ins Ausland verlagern wir täglich länger
klangvolle Namen sind darauf von BSF
Bayer und Bosch über kontinental
Mercedes und Miele bis SAP und ZF
deindustrialisierungsminister habbeck
der bekanntlich Vaterlandsliebe steht
zum kotzenfand fordert die Unternehmen
nun zum Patriotismus auf Pleite zu gehen
das ist das Konzept dieser
Bundesregierung Deutschland steckt tief
in einer Rezession als einziges
Industrieland schrumpft es und dafür
trägt weder Putin die Verantwortung noch
die Welt noch irgendeine
herbeifantasierte
weltklimakatastrophe diese unfähige
Regierung trägt als einzige die
Verantwortung für das Disaster in
unserem
Land und zwar mit ihrer zerstörerischen
Politik der künstlichen
Energieverknappung und
energieverteuerung des unablässigen
Drehens an steuerschrauben der
Verbotspolitik der Enteignung der
Geldverschwendung während sie den Leuten
das Märchen vom reichen Land erzählen
reich ist in Deutschland nur der
überfütterte übergriffige Staat aber
nicht der
Steuerzahler hertausende deutsche
erhalten in diesen Tagen ihre
Heizkostenabrechnung und wissen oft
nicht wie sie sie bezahlen sollen
Normalverdiener Rentner Familien
Mittelständler Freiberufler müssen sich
Jahr für Jahr mehr einschränken um noch
über die Runden zu kommen sie selbst
aber denken gar nicht daran sich
einzuschränken sie gönnen sich neue
Hubschrauber und Fuhrparks ihre
Kabinettsmitglieder geben Unsummen für
Friseure und Fotografen aus die
Außenministerin fliegt mit großem Tross
in peinliche Missionen weltweit während
der
Durchschnittsverdiener nicht weiß was er
sich überhaupt noch leisten kann und sie
halten an ihrem
protzkanzleramt für fast Sage um
schreibe 800 Millionen Euro fest der
gigantomanische
Erweiterungsbau kostet allein fast so
viel wie das jährliche Sonderopfer was
sie den Bauern abverlangen wollen sie
haben den Beamtenapparat hat in nur Z
Jahren um rund
11500 Stellen aufgebläht schön für ihre
Günstlinge schlecht für die Steuerzahler
den der ganze Spaß 8 Milliarden Euro
kostet wo andere Regierungen ihr
internationales Engagement überdenken
und zurückfahren drängen sie sich
überall auf mit dem deutschen Steuergeld
die eigenen Bauern bedrohen sie in der
Existenz um eine knappe Milliarde zu
sparen aber für unsinnig agrarprojekte
in der Welt geben sie weiter hunderte
Millionen Euro aus die vielziitierten
Radwege in Peru sind nur eines von
hunderten überflüssigen
Entwicklungshilfe Vorhaben die in der
Summe den Steuerzahler 33 Milliarden
Euro kosten für nichts nur für ihre NGO
Günstlinge sie verpulvern dieses Geld
ohne
Gegenleistung Kühlschränke in Kolumbien
feministische Außenpolitik in Südafrika
für die Taliban in Afghanistan und für
Hamas Terroristen im Gaza selbst nach
Indien gehen Milliarden obwohl Indien
zum Mond fliegt während bei uns die
Infrastruktur zerfällt die Schulen
vergammeln und die Schüler teilweise
nicht mehr richtig lesen schreiben und
rechnen
können gegen die Gesetze der Physik und
der Logik treiben sie das
planwirtschafts und subvensionsmonster
Energiewende weiter voran
in der Energiepolitik ist Deutschland
der Geisterfahrer der Welt die Kosten
sprengen alle Dimension sie sind der
Hauptgrund für die
Haushaltskrise sie summieren sich auf
fast eine Billion Euro seine eins mit
wie viel Nullen Herr habbeck wissen Sie
nicht das sind keine Investitionen in
die Zukunft das ist die teuerste
Zerstörung einer funktionierenden
Infrastruktur die die Welt je gesehen
hat das Land weiter mit illegalen
Migranten jeder kann kommen keiner muss
gehen sie Bürgern im Akkord neue Wähler
ein verschaffen illegalen über das
chancenaufenthaltsrecht eine
scheinlegalität ihr
abschiebungsbeschleunigungsgesetz ist
ein
abschiebungsverhinderungsgesetz wenn der
Steuerzahler abgelehten Asylbewerbern
auch noch ein Anwalt bezahlen muss um
weiter gegen die überfällige Ausreise zu
prozessieren mit dieser Politik treiben
sie die Kommunen in die Verzweiflung
sprengen die sozial sy verschärfen die
Wohnungsnot und untergraben die innere
Sicherheit aber vor allem sie nehmen den
Deutschen ihre Heimat
über 1000
Frauen werden jedes Jahr Opfer sexueller
Gewalt durch Zuwanderer 7000 seit dem
willkommensputsch der CDU Kanzlerin von
2015 aber darüber schweigen sie darüber
schweigen auch die Medien unter dem
schwindeletikett Bürgergeld haben sie
ein MRA
Magneten geschaffen dessen Kosten längst
außer Kontrolle sind das nächste
Haushaltsloch steht schon vor der Tür
sie lassen die Bürger im Stich wo der
Staat dringend gebraucht würde wo bleibt
die Entschädigung an die vielen
impfgeschädigen ihrer covidimpfung wo
bleibt die eigentlich wo bleibt
überhaupt die Aufarbeitung dieses ganzen
disasters wieder und wieder habe ich
hier aufgeführt was n ist zu bringen
noch mal Schließung und Kontrolle der
Grenzen Zurückweisung illegaler
Einwanderer Rückführung abgelehnter und
krimineller Asylbewerber und jener die
kein Aufenthaltsrecht haben das ist die
Durchsetzung von Recht und Gesetz nach
Jahren des herrschafts des Unrechts sie
wollen Abschiebung kriminalisieren das
haben wir gesehen in ihrer
Kampagne Stopp der Energiewende
Beschränkung der Staatsausgaben und
natürlich Streichung des Bürgergelds für
ausländische Staatsbürger die nie in die
Sozialkassen eingezahlt haben sach statt
Geldleistung ist die Divise aber
rationale Argumente erreichen sie schon
gar nicht mehr sie können Deutschland
nicht gut regieren und sie wollen es
nicht sie richten es zu Grunde und ich
sage ihn auch
warum weil sie ihr eigenes Land weil sie
Deutschland hassen diese Regierung hasst
Deutschland
akzeptieren sie wenigstens die
Möglichkeit eines demokratischen
Machtwechsels und machen sie den Weg
frei für Neuwahlen ich bedanke
mich Weide ist kovorsitzende der AFD
Fraktion und bei der einen und anderen
Zahl die sie hier in ihrem Beitrag
vorgetragen hat ist wie gewohnt
vorsichtgebot insbesondere was die
Zuordnung angeht so mancher Zahl dass
diese Regierung das Land passt ist
allerdings darüber hinaus eine ziemlich
gewagte These um es mal vorsichtig zu
formulieren